[Music]
in texas a small restaurant is gaining a
global audience
not for what's on its menu but rather
from the message
it sends every day austin institution el
arroyo
is serving up what we all need as the
pandemic drags on
janet chamleon has the story
it's margaritas are famous in austin el
arroyo isn't the newest or fanciest
tex-mex in town
but fans say it's just plain good
for decades the restaurant has had a
dual mission filling stomachs
and with this sign feeding the soul what
is it you think about the signs that
speaks to people
it's like talking to it's like laughing
with an old friend i mean there's just
things people can connect with easily
ellis winstanley bought the place nine
years ago inheriting the daily duty tied
to the restaurant's iconic
sign posting something witty or
inspirational
often reflecting current events how hard
is it to come up with new content
every single day so there's a team of
folks that work on it and there's a lot
of user submitted ones now so it's
getting easier
as the social media presence gets larger
more than 600 thousand followers between
instagram facebook and twitter
since the pandemic started about a
thousand new ones each day
a thirst for more than margaritas el
arroyo's
comic relief like this want to see
social distancing
loan somebody some money over the
holidays
i really can't stay baby it's coveted
outside
humor that transcends borders
we've seen it a whole bunch this year
where people are saying hey i live in
the uk or i live in germany or whatever
and i've been following the sign and
it's made me smile through this covid
and when i come to the u.s i want to i'm
going to come visit just before closing
each night
the day's message is replaced by a new
one agreed to by the team
phrase of the day turning a decades-old
marquis into one of austin's
biggest draw i actually have been
wanting to visit this place
so in route to her apartment we saw it
and said oh my goodness we need to stop
so the daily dose of levity has become
an added source of income in these lean
times for restaurants it's so fun like
looking back through these
spawning books mugs magnets and more a
group of people is called a no thang
but mostly the sign is a way to connect
when we're often far apart it's been a
heavy year
i think people have responded very
favorably to having some
light-heartedness brought into their
days
curbside humor a calorie-free serving of
comfort food for hearts and minds
for cbs this morning saturday janet
chameleon
austin and the food ain't bad either how
about that